that's why i tell everybody 100 hours of
education before you buy your first ebay
meanwhile
the second the second they get hot on it
they buy 16 things on ebay
you got your
i perspective want to be happy don't you
want to be happy
[Music]
just wanted to uh talk a little sports
cards so
that's what we're gonna do so if you've
got any questions
you know i know a lot of people are 101
and a lot of people are 201 i know a lot
of people are 301
just to set up the framework um but
leave comments on the side here
um to everyone
um please say hello say what's up and
then if you've got questions
please please put them right into the
chat uh i'm glad all of you are here
um and so basically before we go into it
just kind of like where i'm at like
pretty much besides the way i felt about
social media in 2004
or the way i felt about the internet
itself in 1995
three years ago i got that same kind of
feeling in my stomach that was
kind of similar to like even within
social media like i felt about snapchat
or i felt about tik tok
or when i look at athletes or
um just thinking back to like uh what
just happened here
excuse me somebody should what's
happening in the screen
nice because i lost everybody one second
let me see
i don't know why somebody was able to
share that because i like seeing their
faces
yeah i wouldn't buy that joe burrow card
because the grading company
is bad on that somebody hit something
probably
yeah i'm trying to figure out yeah
no worries
yeah because i like having everybody's
faces um anyway um
just really excited about the space i
think that there's a lot of macro
trends that led to this thank you dustin
uh
i think it's a huge opportunity now at
the same token the reason i wanted to do
something like this is there's a lot of
ways to lose money for example
that card that everybody just saw if
that was somebody's card
it means that somebody just got into the
game bought a joe burrow
card but bought it from a grading
company that is like
i don't even like i've spent zero time
looking at the bobo
as i would call them trading companies
but like i've seen the pgi before i
haven't done the homework on when it was
you know like there was a whole era of
grading that happened right after i got
out of the game
in the mid 90s and i've done my homework
on kind of like the three that i
most care about which is psa sgc and bgs
beckett
but i just so everybody knows again i
put in
six months of homework before i put out
my first post of like there's something
going on here
and that was three three years ago so it
takes a ton of education
there's an ungodly amount of mistakes
that i see my friends making who i've
talked to for an hour
by buying a qualifier psa that means
something they think is rated in eight
but the way the psa company used to do
it it's actually a five
because you know there's just there's a
billion things there's a million
different companies
this is a very deeply education needed
based thing on the flip side
i haven't seen anything like this from a
happiness standpoint in a long time like
my most cynical like like
whether wealth uh you know i think a lot
of you know my background i have a lot
of very well-off friends and i have a
lot of friends that are very much not
well off
and it's been very fascinating to watch
the human dynamics of people that have
gone into this game
i think that we are in a moment i do
think it's like any market i think
there's a lot of things today that the
prices that they are now
in five years are gonna be way way way
less because people like to speculate
on up and coming rookies and and just
taking high risk
on the flip side i think there's some
substantially very smart
investments that are more interesting to
me than a real estate or a stock
sound stock if you go into very classic
kind of very protected places so
lou you're looking at the comments
section maybe will i look at all the
faces and kind of try to get a vibe
maybe you can pick
the question that dustin will turn on or
maybe you can even activate the
questions since you have more knowledge
and that's you can too you're getting
more knowledgeable by a second but i'm
ready to kind of
do questions the setup is very simple
this is something that i did from 1986
to 1994 i loved
i kind of watched it every day since
didn't see anything really meaningful
from a business standpoint it was fun
i would always buy a little theater a
little there but about three years ago
three and a half years ago became
obvious to me
what has happened now which is why i
started making content back then
um i'm flattered i guess is the way i
would say it that people think like i've
i drove it i'm always flattered by that
because i'm like
i mean do people realize how big this
market is and how small
my audience is in the scheme of things
but it's been really interesting
there's a lot going on there's gonna be
a lot of happiness
had there's gonna be a lot of money to
be made there's gonna be a lot of money
that's gonna be lost
because people are gonna make mistakes
in jumping to conclusions and lack of
education
i think the two biggest trends that
everybody should pay attention to are on
the edges
one is what i would call the
contemporary art market
i think that if you studied what
happened from the 1950s to today with
andy warhols and jackson pollocks and
things of that nature
there's a scenario where by the way i'm
getting bombarded people trying to get
in this only holds 500
so if you're just coming because you
want to say what's up or what have you
great but after a while if you're not
interested don't just leave and leave
this on
leave the chat so some people can get in
that are trying to get in but i'm pumped
that all of you are here
contemporary art i i do think you know
hollow first edition shadowless
charizard psa tens if there's only 130
40 of
even though they're 100k today could get
crazy i think psa 10 michael jordan
you know rookie cards that are 80 90 000
today since there's 313 of them could
get crazy if this happens the way i
think
what i mean crazy i mean things going
from 100 000 to a million
a piece the way that jackson pollux and
andy warhol's did so
on the super high end the contemporary
art thing on the
on the low end something i see nobody
talking about
is we talk about pack breaking and all
the stuff that
if you don't know what that is on
youtube people opening up packs pack
breaking
and we talk about it for what it means
for the current hobby but i don't think
people realize how many
seven eight and nine year olds are
watching the living [ __ ] out of those
videos
but they're not in the game yet they're
seven or eight years away from being in
this game
kind of and so it's an incredible
incredible uh what i would say pipe
to giving you a debate that the hobby
can have much longer legs than it being
just a 12 month
or 24 month kind of thing or at least
the hobby is 120 years old
i'm talking about like these spikes that
we saw in the mid 80s
late 80s excuse me early 90s the one
that we're living through right now the
one we saw
in the early 70s early 80s the ones we
saw kind of
in the 50s and 60s these have had cycles
but if you do real economic homework
and look how the card market has
outperformed the s p 500 on the top five
percent premium stuff
historically baseball mickey mantle sam
usual vertical clemente
i think that's getting spread out now
into pokemon soccer
basketball that's why i've spoken about
95 vintage
you know the things i've talked about
have been basically 95
vintage and or 90 vintage and five to
seven young players
that i think have already proven enough
on the field i'm not talking about a
good highlight by bulbal
during a scrimmage i'm talking two three
years of performing
that get me excited of like okay maybe
there's something here
outside of luca which you might remember
two years ago or 18 months ago i got
really excited about because
i just saw enough within 10 games of
like kind of what i need to see so
that's kind of my macro i'd love to get
into q a let's let's rock and roll
um william zimmerman asks
yo gary question do you believe in what
on i want to put them on if you can okay
that's cool can we do that yep
so i want to get some people featured
all right find them
hey come here
i love what's going on in the chat
everybody obviously there'll be so much
stuff here but like the chat i think
could be more vibrant than even what i'm
doing here
so if you're trying to learn if you're
trying to take pay attention to what's
going on
in the chat hey gary what's up man hey
will what's good what's going on man
i've been following you for a while
it's great to talk thanks thank you two
questions uh
i got a rising tide theory question and
then i have a
uh sophomore year card question so if
somebody's psa 10 is skyrocketing
do you believe in buying the uh psa 9
yes kind of like rising tide just raises
all boats type of thing
well my biggest concern is that kids are
gonna get priced out or people that
can't afford are gonna get priced out
so i'm excited about the psa eight and
nine market
i even think the eight market is
interesting
yeah i mean you've seen it right you've
seen it so yes i absolutely believe that
i also think it hits cross-pollination
vintage basketball's finally had its
moment i'm starting to really study
vintage football
because i'm like wait a minute if walter
payton and you know
and oscar robinson were kind of comped
but now oscar's gone up 7x but walter
stayed in the pocket
is that an arbitrage so yes i think the
rising tide matters
i think it goes to cross uh brand we've
seen prism lucas go bananas and then all
of a sudden you start seeing
the hoops or the optic go but so i think
yes i think there's a lot of that
in this and i think for vintage
specifically
eight seven sixes fives it's hard to get
excited about a psa five modern
i don't think anybody here is gonna get
excited but i do think eights
is still an interesting play and raw
we've seen raw forget about even grading
so
yes i think i fully believe in rising
tides one more question and then uh
software your cards
if rookie cards are getting way too
expensive uh for example
not for not for not for me okay but but
guess what
i'm 0.000
of the hobby and the market not for me
i've never been interested in year two
cards
you know my brother's getting excited
about champions
first championship year card yeah for
basketball players yeah aj's like hot on
that
doesn't doesn't go crazy for me but it's
an interesting theory
um
i think if first year cards get too
expensive if you're looking from an
investment standpoint
you look at alternative first-year cards
right i saw
rylan show a wade tops card i i started
buying a ton of bazooka
lebrons you know when it was like
getting crazy like so i'm just not hot
on year two cards
but guess what in five years maybe
that's the [ __ ] jam and
you know that's cool but not not for me
okay cool thank you very much man you
got it bro
go ahead dustin yep henry
mack i like that jackie robinson [ __ ]
come on henry taylor
gill henry taylor come on down
all right
henry what's good yeah hey can you hear
me cool kev
where are you from what this is crazy
man i've always wanted to talk to you
this is surreal right now but
um my question is to do with like
vintage and i know you're big into
vintage i'm big intervention
vintage and i bought a george german off
your recommendation
um but my question is like going forward
i know you're big on nostalgia and i
know you're big on nostalgia for brands
my question is what happens when you
have like someone like bob mcadoo
because i was looking at your
uh twitter polls you've been doing like
who's the greatest ex or who's the
greatest quarterback who's
who's better amongst these i never say
by the way on the record
because i enjoy what i'm doing on
twitter everybody gets mad at me they're
like what about this guy like no no
compare these four i'm not saying these
are the four best but go ahead
yeah um but i've noticed like the trend
with that is it's a hundred percent
recency but it's like you can waste
every single every single time it's a
younger crew on twitter
and so the more current great always
outperforms
others within the context i
i um which is why i never like live and
die based on those polls
to be frank this is good for all of you
to know i'm really not doing those polls
for data for me to buy cards i'm doing
them
because i'm so in the [ __ ] card
cocoon right now
that i just like start asking these own
questions for me and i'm just curious
what other people think too
so you know twitter's date is too dirty
for that to be an indicator
of me to do something business-wise but
it's just kind of literally when i'm
studying population reports on sgc bgs
and psa
watching old videos or looking for
angles on things that i'm trying to
figure out
it's literally spur of the moment that i
get excited about a poll like that and i
just put it out for fun so
listen i think the thing that you know i
did a podcast yesterday and the kids
were deep in the game and were very
cynical of when i first came into it
and they got a real lesson in how deep
i'm in this [ __ ] right now like i do a
lot of homework
i'm doing a lot of studying yeah yeah no
i mean
the the essence of my question is
basically in like 20 years time does
anyone remember who mcadoo is or does
anyone remember who
some guy from the 70s was who maybe
wasn't
henry you'll appreciate this now they
don't remember now yeah exactly which is
why they were underpriced
yeah exactly but that's a should i would
they be worth buying then
on that basis or nobody alive right now
watched
you know hank greenberg play but see
baseball did all the work for us
you can do a ton of homework on what's
happened with the baseball card market
over the last 90 years and that's why
i'm doing what i'm doing
next year is the nba's 75th anniversary
they're going to put out the 75 best
players of all time just like they did
on the 50th anniversary
that's going to start creating all sorts
of lists and all sorts of debates
all of a sudden artist gilmore and bob
mcadoo and george
they start getting a little fame out of
that bob lanier and you start getting a
little action right and
that's what we'll see i mean that espn
list is is gospel for me that top 74
players
like i look at that list all the time
and i analyze it i also think that we
saw with the last dance
the ability for documentaries to bring a
lot of interest
once lance last dance dominated in
hollywood right now there's a billion
basketball documentaries in the making
and all of a sudden connie hawkins and
oscar robinson and will chamberlain like
you know this is that's what happens
history plus now you live in a
spotify quibby world so you don't need
to make a feature film on jackie
robinson
you can make a for example i'm talking
to dominique wilkins right now to do a
four-part podcast series
you know maybe about him maybe about his
favorite players so like you're gonna
see a lot of content come out that's
gonna educate the kids
plus it's fun it's fun to look back at
[ __ ] and i think more and more people
are gonna do it and people gonna look
for angles
not only that when money starts
happening for real
older money people start coming you're
about to see a huge influx of 45
62 71 59 year old businessmen and women
coming into the hobby
and they do know who bob lamir and
mcadoo are and when they look
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
kendrick nun psa tens are more expensive
than bob mcadoo they're gonna buy bob
mcadoos
yeah that's my point that's kind of
right that's what i'm thinking
awesome cheers all right let's keep it
moving i appreciate everybody being here
i'm scrolling through all these screens
seeing all the
handsome and beautiful faces i
appreciate all of you i'm glad you're
all here
and by the way take advantage of this
moment there's a lot of people in here
that are gonna be i
like that abel i like that garyvee
signed card in there i see you sharing
that on the screen
um uh please please please please
share your twitter handles right now in
the chat
everybody especially if they're linked
urls this is an incredible opportunity
for a lot of you to get to know each
other and build french like literally i
expect
at the national in chicago two of you
coming up to my table and be like we met
on that [ __ ] saturday
zoom so like yes we're here yapping but
like
please i see i love this watching what's
going on with you and by the way notice
how some people are urling it and some
are adding it
do the url because it's easier for
people to just click them and
[ __ ] start following each other
because obviously we're all in that same
wave in here
let's keep it going dust next will be
corey donovan
corey get in here hey what's good gary
hey
this is corey aka yamwax
on social hey man i'm looking at this
uh this boom in cards going straight
into the football season right now
and with fantasy football and all that
and the new investors
are we gonna see skill positions like
wide receivers tight ends running backs
start to pop week to week or even
you know ongoing yep we sure are yeah so
for any of the newbies in here the
thing i was told three years ago by some
of the ogs that i was coming in i'm
learning learning learning
they're like gary the hobby doesn't like
anybody in football besides quarterbacks
and i was like okay but my biggest thing
corey three years ago was the hobby is
going to get redefined
because if there's 50 000 people in it
now this is what i was thinking back
then
but there's gonna be five million in it
that 50 000 is a very small percentage
so what rules are going to be redefined
right and so i think you're going to see
an explosion of fantasy
and gamblers coming into sports cards
this year
and i think receivers i know lou i'm
looking at little lou on here
i know he's gone focused on receivers
like
i'm i'm a big believer that football
is next vintage football's my focus but
i do think that you know i'm not buying
aj greens or julio joneses or
even younger guys like amari cooper but
do i think there's real real real money
to be made
in like a short-term arbitrage i do and
i think that in a long-term arbitrage
they have to be
i think where everybody gets caught is
some if you're betting on new kids
eventually somebody's sitting with the
bag
because to really be worth something
they have to be a top 50 player of all
time
so like like i learned this in my
teenage years
around todd van popp i bought 4 000
david justice rookie cards
when older guys like a very small group
back then was saying no buy ernie banks
buy clemente and i'm like [ __ ] you old
guy and that's who i am now
the action for all these kids is in the
new guys
and so like yo gary you go into a card
shop i recommend anybody do it flip
through like early 90s sports cards
in the early 2000s you see guys like
clint and portis they're totally
forgotten so you're right you do have to
know the absolute stars
that's right think back to all the guys
who crushed
seven by the way look basketball is at
the height and look at what a ray allen
or chris bosh
is doing nothing yeah and like those are
real guys
and if this was happening during the
heat's run krishbosch rookies would be
through the roof
you're going to get a lot of people to
get caught with a lot of modern but yes
i do
think in the short term the football
scares the [ __ ] out of me because
you were perfectly right about amari
cooper and he breaks his [ __ ] leg and
he won
that could happen uh that can happen uh
paddy mahomes or lamar jackson too
though so you know it's a tough game
i agree football is tough football is
tough but
cool man love it thank you brother talk
to you later
[Music]
up next will be adam robles
hey gary adam how are you bro good how
are you
super well man awesome so i want to ask
you a question i'm a i'm from toronto
i'm a huge raptor fan
um we have a stack team and we have a
bunch of young guys but i feel like they
don't get a lot of press
i agree they play uh for the raptors and
they play in canada
yeah it's worth it investing in guys
like pascal og
i'm obsessed with og yeah okay yeah as a
i believe in his game i'm scared that
all prism rookies are expensive
yeah like like i sat and watched og
highlights for like four hours
that's not true 45 minutes but it felt
like six years
and then i went to ebay i'm like i'm
gonna steal this [ __ ] kid and they're
already expensive
yeah you know so it's like a little hard
but yeah no listen
if somebody's great they're great and
don't forget bad for you
but but good for the card investment if
you know 80 of those guys are gonna
leave on the max contract
yeah okay you know i don't want that for
you as a raptors fan i mean i hate the
raptors because i'm a knicks fan but
like
for you that sucks but you know
those eight i would argue that six out
of ten of those guys are gonna go
to a big market on their yeah you guys
are alone i mean terence davis
sayakam og like those guys are it's like
i think you might win the title this
year yeah no hundred percent
it's crazy i mean i mean if i mean
[ __ ] if kawhi let state forget it you
would have moonwalked
yeah um yeah so i yeah i don't think i
yes
it hurts a little but but good is good
and it always works out got it okay
pittsburgh is a small market
but like you know but like if you're
good you're good yeah
okay no that's good to know thank you i
mean bro nobody even knew where golden
state was
15 years ago i was literally being san
francisco in tech all those nerds didn't
care about sports i'd be like what about
the warriors like what's that i'm like
golden state they're like where's that
while i was in san francisco right so
like if you're good
good works every time okay all right now
i appreciate that thank you
you got it cheers
up next will be john evans
hey gary what's good john what's going
on brother
oh well thanks so much for doing this
man
i i'm really interested in stuff that's
on you know you mentioned doing some
recent research around things that you
think are untapped or undervalued
i'm curious if there's anything you'd
want to share here that you found i know
as i've been trying to kind of
leave no stone unturned i've looked
especially at the starting lineup
sets i'm a fan i've been buying
i only own probably about 50 or 60 but
i've been buying starting lineup cards
i've i've been buying starting lineups
figures to rip the card out
yeah that's what i've been doing as well
that one's especially interesting just
because
it's got really low pop in the in the
pop report but then also
a lot of the starting lineup collectors
kept them in the packaging so even if
everything else does but also they're
also good-looking cards especially the
early stuff
right yeah i'm a buyer
lou might be laughing right now because
i bought a stack of raw starting lineups
at the national last year i came back i
was all fired up he was excited he
thought i brought back something good
and then he like made fun of me but like
i really
i i like them i i listen i believe over
the next half decade anything that has
low pop
and ever had cultural relevance has a
chance
okay all right well that's cool i i felt
like a mad scientist as i bought those
and then try to cut them out of the
packaging and
i think you're on to something i also
like i also
and i really love branded cards
right you know i think i i just really
like the icy bear 72 set i've been on
the record on that
i see holding one up right now i'm
obsessed with that set
sugar daddy 74's the little ones
you know 68 jack in the box san diego
clipper cards
that weird [ __ ] really has my attention
because i think it's extremely rare and
all you need is a little bit
of demand and it gets berserko so
i last question along those lines with
the sort of
more obscure stats like the icy bear
do you think along the lines of your art
uh cards imitating art thesis when you
have
cards like this that are jumbo and
bigger i'm thinking so
if if this replaces art and people hang
this up
and i don't think they're gonna i don't
think we're gonna hang it up but i do
think you're gonna see some display
cases built that people can
like hang up their 25 best ones so like
i think the 5x7 stuff like the interlake
jordan
and all that stuff like you may see some
stuff happen but i don't think you take
i do think bigger cards and smaller
cards again
rules of the old hobby i think go away
so i don't think size matters
in any shape or form going forward i
really don't that's kind of what i've
been wondering because you have like
these little small
stickers like the 1986 dr j
yeah but these are the small spanish
stickers and then you have like these
jumbo cards and i'm wondering
if one or the other is going to be
better than just your regular
one man's point of view it could be
totally wrong i think it plays out that
neither size matters okay but i think a
lot of people in the hobby have thought
standard cards only
and that's where there's an arbitrage
awesome thank you so much man for what
you're doing for the hobby very cool
thank you john
um we're just getting a lot of questions
about like how to start so i don't know
if you want to just make like a
nice statement for them yeah lou may
there's a lot of starters in here can
you
link like 50 times in a row in my chat
that
url that you guys made on my blog that
has all the links that we think
is this 10 hour starter kit to get all
the rules down thank you for all the
really really noobs
which you know i was just three and a
half years ago but i had like a decade
of experience but you needed to get
refreshed on all the new rules
we'll put a bunch of things here and
please feel free to share it out and
things of that nature
and and lou because you're so sharp on
this [ __ ] wanna since dustin's picking
questions why don't you
read the chat pretty aggressively lou
and then maybe jump in with some
questions in between quick fire
questions that seem to be common or
he's pretty much doing that and then
he's just sending me names awesome
so lou feel free to jump in occasionally
and just if you see something that's
interesting
that you just asked the question on
behalf go ahead dust uh liam wasserman
liam what's up gary what's good bro uh i
had two
questions so what do you think
like why do you think base cards are
beginning to outsell certain autographs
uh cost of entry there's so many more
people into this now but there's
but at first they i mean this is
expensive [ __ ] liam and not everybody a
lot of people are collecting not just
flipping and it's hard to buy a silver
for six thousand bucks
you know or or a one of one or kaboom 10
or
so i think bait whenever the hobby is
very popular
when there's a lot of demand base will
always do better
what you grew up with it sounds like by
you asking that question which is you
were in it before this boom
yeah i was i've been in it for about
seven or eight years perfect the demand
was much lower
right so so that demand group didn't
want the bases because there was a lot
of supply they went after the one
of 100 the 101 got it so as demand
grows the base grows with it
and then i also had another question
about like how do you feel like
celebrities in the game so like you
steve aoki mark wahlberg are all
big accounts that are starting to put
out sports cards how do you think that's
going to affect the market
oh i think that's what the next wave is
i think you know wahlberg's on a
different level and aoki's a different
level than me for that matter too
like i've always said this the last year
you've probably heard it i'm like you
guys think i'm [ __ ] wait do you see
what's gonna happen i mean i think we're
moments away
from the coolest people doing it top 10
rappers
top 10 athletes and then it's going to
be [ __ ] game
over yeah because i've seen like you on
your podcast like telling who was it
like serge ibaka investing cards
again serge is like he hit me up the
other day serge by the way
to the gentleman uh i don't see him uh
to the
toronto kid serge told me about terence
davis that's why i started really
looking at him
um again serge is a great solid nba
player but i'm like talking like
dwyane wade and the baby and gunna
and t.i and tyga and [ __ ] you know
like
like real fame yeah but then you that
but then you have to
think like maybe cards might start to be
start to get too expensive for people
like me i'm i'm 18.
i'm not going to afford all this while
i'm in college of course
but two things will happen one since
you've been in seven years
that's gonna escalate so much that
you're gonna have more capital
if you deplete it if you're not just
holding two
it will adjust and you'll look at nines
and eights or like
me and others are looking for starting
lineups or like like the
you grew up and most of the people i
talk to that have been in it for 10
years or more
grew up in an era where it was tiny
so it was concentrated yeah psa
10 you know limited cards right
yeah what you're about to watch happen
is the complete expansion of something
that is going to make 59 things
important not just
one because i know personally i've been
all modern but i'm starting to look into
vintage so like my pc i'm a i'm a
cleveland fan i go to ohio state so like
i'm looking into a 58 tops jim brown
that i want to buy and yeah
do me a favor buy a 58 jim brown
immediately
because that one's about to get bananas
bananas yeah there's
i'm i'm looking into a couple low grade
just because that's what i can afford
but
i respect that i would tell you one of
the ways that a lot of smart kids are
gonna win
is they're gonna buy and sell very hot
things
like a tatum or mitchell or a michael
porter junior
take profits and go into more scarce
vintage
that's where i see kids really amassing
true wealth
in this era yeah because i want to look
into vintage as more of a long-term hold
while i'm in my four years of college
just to
liam but i think everybody's starting to
learn everyone's like gary vintage
doesn't go up as fast
and they were all telling me that but
like gary the new stuff goes so feminine
i'm like cool you don't understand the
second vintage demand
rises there's no [ __ ] inventory right
i was buying psa [ __ ] eight
dr jays a year ago for 700 bucks
now they're [ __ ] five six thousand
seven eight
nine thousand right and i saw i saw john
snyder who's driving put up thumbs up so
you know i'm taking that as a contextual
guy who's been in it for a while or
understands his point in his head like
either he sees it or he's lived it
listen i lived this already it was
called 1986-1994
did i do the same mistake i'm trying to
tell a lot of kids not to make
which is i got excited about everything
that was happening of the moment
now you should still do that that's why
people gamble that's why people watch
sports i get it
but if you're really trying to build
like i want to buy a house with this one
day i want to start a career like
it is about supply and demand and the
vintage stuff is such
an important place to look at yeah
by the way back to ohio state braxton
miller hit me up uh
a week ago and said i want to get in so
i'm talking yeah i'm on campus right now
i'm a first year so
enjoy all right let's keep it moving
i haven't looked into blockchain i saw
the blockchain question over and over i
haven't really looked at blockchain i
like my blockchain is very simple like i
believe in blockchain technology
in 2015 i bought some bitcoin after a
funny
debate night on at south by southwest i
did extremely well
but i have not been active in it right
now i actually see the physical nature
of the cards acting like contemporary
art
but i'm but blockchain is a technology
that will all be affected by through the
years it'll be plenty of opportunity
it's just not where i'm putting my
energy right now
gee a lot of people are asking about uh
like soccer vintage soccer
obsessed um yeah i think i'll make it
i'll make it very simple
up cessed period
i think one of the for me by the way
back to clarity
lou you know this as well as i do what
do i have 25 cards i have very little
inventory
um yeah but i think something that i
would
want to hear about is like when it comes
to
i think a lot of people are looking for
when it comes to modern stuff people are
looking for prism they're looking for
tops chrome because that's stuff they
know
when you get into vintage when you get
into vintage soccer especially it's like
the most random [ __ ] ever
cut out of magazines yeah and like what
is the brand called like no one knows
what the actual card is so
i think all of it is in play the grading
companies did it for you
you know and i'm seeing josh and share
one of his cards on the screen
like you and lou you know you know
what's fun lou
is you've been with me and guys lou
who's on the screen right now or just
was talking
you know he's my admin but i've known
him since he was six we're jet bands
together his dad and i are great friends
like three years ago when i was like yo
we're doing this
he kind of laughed about it but he was
into it and helped me lou you know this
i was about the weird stuff from the
beginning the handcuff the 52 wheaties
were the first things i was buying 52
wheaties like the most random [ __ ]
i've ever seen in my life right so like
like i'm not scared by any of the random
50s 60s 70s soccer stuff all of it is
interesting to me
as you know lou i'm the one thing i
haven't gone into is the postcards
i'm a little that's literally the only
thing i haven't bought but like all of
it i think has to be
lou here's why and everybody's watching
and bottle caps
yes i did built i did bid on an actual
soda bottle cap on ebay and everybody
made fun of me the other day
um uh i think the hobby will evolve its
point of view on things
i but if it's graded and that means
kind of official i think all of it is in
play to be debated of
pele's got like seven different cards
that are debated as the rookie card
ali all this stuff like i think all of
it's gonna be debated jerry p i'm gonna
make sure that card's worth a lot of
money for you one day
um yeah so so i think soccer is
there's a lot to learn you know i've
started by educating me
myself on who the 50 greatest players
are since i didn't grow up really being
hardcore
doing a lot of homework it's the global
sport basketball is emerging
as the new and next global sport which
is why i'm so bullish on it
obviously i understand it a lot better
the world cup is going to be super
exciting
you know you also have a potential
generational talent
if he stays healthy with mumbai
happening at the same time so there's a
lot of interesting stuff going on in
soccer
um soccer and pokemon are very important
to all of this conversation because they
are gateway drugs to people that don't
like the big four sports in america
and so i'm watching a lot of people get
into a lot of things
because um pokemon and soccer are
getting them in
and then that gets them john i love your
emotions
i guess you're agreeing with me john
slater um i think pokemon and soccer are
getting people that would have never
considered cards back in the day in
and then they're bleeding into football
and basketball and
other things the same way i mean i'm
watching basketball only kids
get into juan soto and and and fernando
tatis jr it's just ha
i'm going to say one more time i am very
good at pattern recognition
it is why i've predicted so many things
right it's why i'm successful
along with some other dynamics but it is
one of my great skills
i've seen these patterns before i lived
them in 1985 and 86
and it's just happening again but it's
happening with the internet
it's happening with youtube pack
breaking it's happening on the back of
the 86 to 93 era where i became obsessed
but now i have money so there's like
and so do five thousand fifty thousand
five hundred thousand others
so you're getting a different wave
because when it happened 86 to 93
the parents of that era they weren't the
generation that was in love with cards
when they were kids so they were like
what they were like kind of
what you're seeing is kids dragging
parents and parents dragging kids in
it's a bigger dynamic this time it is
uh up next is column column
[Music]
sorry i can't pronounce it hey gary
pleasure to be on
nice to have you on colin so uh my
question had to do with so i've been
preaching to my friends
saying you know what get on this get on
this it's early and uh
like kind of everyone i've talked to
says that again i know you're into
super into vintage and stuff and i've
kind of been focused on modern right now
and moving that money into vintage but
everyone i've talked to thinks that
it's like gambling like you're betting
on players to win and
i see a lot of people making quick money
like that i just wondering what your
thoughts are on
it is gambling yeah so you would say
straight gambling too
i wouldn't say it's straight gambling
because the reason i started yelling
three years ago
and the people that jumped on i knew the
whole thing was gonna go up
so it was almost like everything's gone
like if you're losing money in cards
right now
turn off the computer and never go into
business again
yeah like like like that's what happens
when
it explodes now we're starting to enter
the next phase
where it is more i mean you see what
people are paying for national treasure
rpas of kids that have
that 90 of those kids are not going to
make it yeah
now if they flip it quickly it's day
trading versus buying apple stock for
five years
yeah i'm playing this the way i play the
stock market i buy 712 things and i sit
on it forever
i'm not day trading 90 of this room
right now and the
twitter and social are day trading
that's fine i don't get to judge how one
plays it
but that is gambling now i think when
you do it with devin booker
and acuna versus michael porter jr
and [ __ ] jason dominguez it's a
different level of gambling
yeah right yeah right so so
i think when you're betting on 16 year
old prospects in bowman you are
completely rolling your [ __ ] dice
i think when you watch a season like
acuna last year and the [ __ ] pedigree
you're not gambling as much now you're
in derrick rose gambling territory which
means
which means everything could be right
and we're all right about acuna and kurt
dee's point is braves had he's fired up
but
yeah but acuna could become bo jackson
get
hurt and not happen yeah i lived through
bo jackson i lived through penny
hardaway i lived through grant hill
i lived through that yeah you know
what's fun about vintage
jerry west is always going to be the
logo jerry west is always going to be a
12-time
og jerry west is always going to be the
guy that [ __ ] traded vlady divots for
for [ __ ] kobe bryant jerry west is
always going to be one of the iconic old
white guys that could play
jerry west is going nowhere yeah long
term you can't go wrong
you can go unbelievably wrong with
every single i mean you know how much
money potentially is going to be lost on
zion
oh yeah no no no zion could go on to be
you know [ __ ] lebron and but but the
potential
i promise you this between zion john
moran
jason dominguez like there's some real
money going to be lost in this era
maybe not by the people that are sitting
now because they're flipping it but
somebody's gonna be sitting with the bag
yeah just straight collection design and
i and i don't want to be sitting with a
bag i'm buying things forever
okay and and and and that's it
yeah i know well thank you very much you
got it brother
uh up next is tommy hayes
zion could be sean kemp that's a great
example do you understand if this was
the nba final season
sean of the sonics versus the [ __ ]
bulls how expensive gary payton and sean
campbell
cards would be right now like kids are
not
thinking now they're day trading which
is okay i'm telling you
my i haven't figured out the piece of
content yet but at some point i'm
definitely gonna put out
hey kids be a great day trader take 30
50
off the rack and put it into something
that's long term and just keep playing
that game
i think that could be because then
they've got something for themselves one
day
it's also why i love pokemon pikachu's
not gonna tear his acl
let's keep it going um
[Music]
i just unmuted someone but i forgot who
was gonna give him
hey gary this is uh tommy tommy what's
good
uh i had a question about i've seen a
big trend on
uh vintage basketball football baseball
reprints
and then people going getting him psa'd
and then
putting a walter payton rookie for 1300
out there that's a reprint education
education education it's something
i'm just saying you see these people
like you know just keep on doing it or
you know my hope tommy is that somebody
here in this room that doesn't know how
they want to enter this industry
decides to start a twitter account or a
social media account
that lists everybody who's trying to
trick people with qualifiers and
reprints
and becomes one of the five biggest
accounts in the whole sports card hobby
because everybody references it and it
stops people from being [ __ ] faces
yeah i agree i think that's a by the way
for anybody who's kind of clever or
wants to do something a little different
i think that would be a monster account
but tommy that tommy that's why i tell
everybody 100 hours of education before
you buy your first ebay meanwhile
the second the second they get hot on it
they buy 16 things on ebay and buy a
[ __ ]
psa 8 qualifier and get ripped off they
buy a reprint and get ripped off they
buy a
they buy a [ __ ] grading company beat
you know bccg
yeah and like people make [ __ ]
mistakes oh yeah
i see these clown bags out here doing
this and i'm just like you're gonna
push away too many people from the
industry and piss too many people off
the good news is if i feel like the
reason i'm being loud around education
is i'm hoping the next people that have
big audiences pick up on that and
hopefully that will be a big
and we all got to keep pushing that and
and you know i can't control
trimming and things of that nature like
that gets hard that's like fbi [ __ ] but
like
the common stuff of like you know
reprints or [ __ ]
or or the qualifiers really trick people
heavy tommy
yeah the psa sub qualifiers people are
getting ripped off heavy
oh yeah thanks man thank you bro
thank you man um
a lot of people asking about the future
of ufc
trading cards i don't know uh some of
you
know vaynersports is now in the ufc game
we're repping some pretty legit dudes
we've got a main event tonight um and uh
and i'm literally starting my process of
ufc homework this weekend i think
um so i believe in ufc i think ufc is a
really good spot i haven't done
any homework have no clue on population
um
only starting to get my education i'm a
bigger i was a historically bigger
boxing fan
than i was ufc but i've always dabbled
but now that we're in the business i'm
heavy deep
and so i have a lot more to say in the
next year but if you know ufc
um it's definitely somewhere to look at
because boxing cards golfing cards
tennis cards like when
and again i'm looking at a lot of faces
in here even some of us older cats in
here
we're going to see another entire cycle
this is going to be this era and what is
it going to be 12 months 49 months 62
months i'm not [ __ ]
nostradamus i have no clue how long this
happens but what i can tell you is it's
gonna hap it's already happened
like i said it would we're in it it's
gonna have a run
and then whatever it is the global
economy something else
just general fatigue of everybody being
hot on it together for five years and it
gets boring like every other thing in
life and then there'll be a dip
and then again 7 12 19 years later
they'll come right back this has been
120 years in the making
so that's why i want you sitting on
jordans and
and you know and bronze and dr jays and
walter payton's not like michael porter
jude and michael porter might turn out
to be but like
the gambling is so high on modern
jackson
hey gary hello jackson
hey so i had a question about um
what do you think is better investment
for baseball either prospect cards or
the rookie cards
like i have this bowman acuna
um prospect card i didn't know if you'd
rather have it
yeah it felt like for a long time bowman
was winning the day
the hobby had bowman but we've seen a
major
surge on top's first
appearance in series two or update and i
i think
i think it will continue to evolve
jackson i think you play the arbitrages
it might end up being heritage in seven
years and that was the right arm so i
think
i think you hedge you know commit to
anything it was very clear that it was
bowman
three years ago to me when i did my
backlog homework tops has closed the gap
quite a bit in the last 18 months but i
think both of them are quite sound
the problem is right like you look at
eloy jimenez who's having a great year
right now right
what hurts bowman a little bit is that
he's in his cubs uniform
and he's a white sock and you think
about those kind of dynamics a little
bit a lot of these minor league guys
switcheroo
versus when they hit as a rookie and
are awesome they lock in for quite a
while on that team so there's a little
bit of that
right i think one of the reasons you
know moses malone for example is
underrated
is because he played for like nine
different teams but had he played in one
place for one time right i
i think about like those things i always
think about wade boggs
probably under price because he became a
yankee and it's like boston pants can't
go
there right maybe even lukey betts for
that reason though i think he has two
great fan bases that are less
direct rivals so these are all the
things that run through my [ __ ] head
okay thank you you're welcome i'll also
say on the top spelman thing
gee like tatis is an example of the guy
who popped off this year like
his bowman his bowman is still
you know 800 and his top series 2 is
only like 260.
yep so like the bowman still does carry
a pretty big premium for a lot of guys
i think so but i think we've seen tops
close the gap i agree with you
and i'm i'm on the side i think tops is
better but that's just my personal
opinion yeah i mean you know it's like
yeah i think i think they'll evolve you
know i think that um
i think it's gonna be interesting to
watch a ball that i i do think tops
will continue to close the gap
intuitively i think so
i also think it's a price point that's a
little more affordable
to the youngsters i also think tops and
you know lou
when we did that step with them i yelled
at them i'm like make your regular
product good
they finally did this year with like
some parallels and some autos
otherwise it's boring as [ __ ]
jerry i think we can block the sexo
sexoanal
okay he's not i think he's not looking
to bring value
not a lot of sports card questions yeah
i don't think sex so sex i don't know if
that's like
you know i don't know if i like penis i
like penis is like some hot
some hot pitcher and you know dominican
republican right now but i'm gonna i'm
gonna lean towards
brian daniel's not bringing value
all right let's keep it going by the way
biggest roi biggest reason i jumped in
here
is if you're following me and wanted to
be in here and you're about the subject
matter
there's a substantially strong situation
that you want to be um
that you can be friends with each other
so after this is done
please go to twitter and use the hashtag
thatwasfungv
that was fun gv this way you can all
find each other
and maybe get into combos follow make
some trades buy from each other whatever
you'd like to do so
let's get that hashtag in there that was
fun gb let's get a couple more in here
real quick
jerry hey hey hey can you hear me i can
all right
great so uh i had a question i
i've got like two thousand dollars into
the sports cards
and i'd like to say i've got some pretty
big stuff i've got like a zion silver
tin here
um i've got to load them in bobby's i
mean i was buying them when you said to
buy them
i got them at 52 bucks apiece i still
had to pay 20 bucks to get them graded
but at what point do you cash out
and what i mean by that is do i do i
sell one card to get all the money back
and have a little safety so it's all
free money or
okay that's always a good idea now the
problem is
you know you may sell something that
gets you all your money back at three
thousand bucks
and then watch it go to 11 000 be like
what the [ __ ] so
the only time to cash out is at the
moment that was the right time to cash
out
and nobody can tell you that okay well
so i'm a dave ramsey nut
uh i literally just used the stimulus
money that i got because i was like well
it's free money you know might as well
go for it
uh you know how do you how do you decide
what to sit
to sell out because i've got like five
mimbapes
you know i've got this one that i'm
keeping forever because you know
you're just the real og like
you're part of a new grade of people
that you know
what's really wild about the people that
came in
through my funnel is the stuff that i
pushed giannis
luca mumbai went so crazy
that a lot of people made a lot of while
the hobby was like
trying to figure out if i was full of
[ __ ] or bad or good the my audience
ended up doing extremely well on those
bets lebron chrome and so you know
you've got to decide is this something
you love is this something interesting
to you
is this something that you are learning
about or was it something that you
believed in me
you decide you believed in you know
turning your stimulus into something and
now you're sitting here
you might be the kind of guy that should
just sell right now and that's amazing
you made a lot of money
but if you're seeing like wait a minute
i like pokemon i like sports or i like
something
and i want to learn more it depends on
how much more you want to get educated
your answer to mumbai brother
is doing homework on mumbai
understanding that he may go to the
premier league and what
understanding that the world cup's in
qatar in the winter of 20 like
education is how you make these
decisions i have a huge advantage
that i live the life i live now where i
actually dm with
juan soto and fernando tatis and like
get to know these kids
and then decide are they a knucklehead
or are they trying to work
at all times to become great and then
that helps me make decisions it's all
data and information
well honestly so the whole reason why i
honestly got into the sports cards was
to
learn how to build a youtube page and i
would really like to come work for
you or dave ramsey as a content creator
this right here is my
favorite card this was the only credit
it was a
credit card that i had i cut it in half
to do the dave rams and stuff
debt free i was going to send it off to
psa
but i really appreciate your time but
jerry
you're on the right path so keep making
content by the way
you were probably the perfect guy to get
deeply educated and make
and make the social media account that
tommy and and i were just talking about
which is the one that
you need probably 200 hours of education
so you don't so you have a good account
but it's posting like auctions that are
trying to trick people like who knows
maybe that's your
thing uh well i was going to say one way
to tell everybody the safest way to get
into sports cards i've just been going
out to walmarts
and using free capital that i had they
put out 600 bucks worth of mosaic i
tripled my money in 10 days on ebay and
i mean
that's and by the way it's insane and
that flip has spurred a lot of emotion
in the hobby because they're mad about
the people that are buying
everything and that's on walmart to try
to figure out if they have to start
limiting and this is all
human and economic dynamics everybody
has to figure out
what works for them people you know
people say that's not right and i'm like
look i struggled to tell another man how
to feed their family
right if it's not illegal it's very hard
to tell you know like
everybody people are in control panini's
in control their business walmart and
target and control their business
everybody here is in control of their
business so there's a million ways to
get educated
and there's a million ways to play it
but i think good
honest kindness and real education and
trying to do it the right way
there's so many ways to win in this and
it's enormously fun and it makes
watching sports fun
and first look at me i'm 95 vintage i
love sports
but i just think there's so much i get
so much fun in doing research
and figuring out that there was a cookie
company that made a 1954
hank aaron card and i think that's weird
and cool
and because i think it's gonna go more
art on the super high end
i think some of these cards that are
four thousand dollars that are weird
that nobody wants
could end up being three million dollars
i'm not kidding yeah yeah there's a
million ways to play
or you want to do patrick mahomes
because you think he's gonna win for the
next five super bowls mazel tov do you
well hey man i really appreciate you so
much gary like
you are the best man i've i've read your
books
listen to you daily man just keep up the
good work thank you so much
thank you so much sneak one or two more
in here
cody caro hey
gary hey what's good what's up so
funny story um you actually you and lou
actually bought a plane ticket for me to
come to the national
unfortunately got got cancelled i
remember but uh hopefully we'll be able
to meet soon
so i got a question about card breaks by
the way that's the other thing that i
really love about this hobby right
like like i think you know i've tried to
bring a ton of kindness to it
you know again i'm not confused and a
lot of you are in it and i know what
people think about me or
did think about me but like there's so
many
you know like like buying buying
somebody a plane ticket to come to the
national is like the karma that i love
living on
and it's like really fun and i think for
a lot of you if you're doing really when
you made a lot of money
like helping a kid get into it or
stopping somebody from making mistakes
maybe instead of posting all your flexes
of sports cards every day
posting an article that teaches somebody
how not to buy a qualifier
like like there's a lot of ways to give
back
yeah of course go ahead my friend so my
question is about card breaks
they're getting more and more popular
now and it seems like almost everybody
wants to get
into it yeah it's fun yeah of course
that's why i got into it myself
um so i've been doing it since february
i've been trying to grow a community
around it not just
for them to you know join my breaks but
just around the hobby in general
how can i kind of like stand out as a
new card breaker
that's going to be completely based on
your skills this was the question
everybody asked me on twitter and
youtube in 2006 because i was blowing up
they're like how do i stand out and my
answer was be good
and being good comes in a million forms
you're attractive
that's good that works you're funny that
works
you're deeply educational you're
entertaining you you came up with a
random idea that was different than
anybody else had ever done it that way
it's all the same [ __ ] brother cool yeah
i've um i've actually tried that in the
beginning
in the beginning let me give you let me
give everybody a good piece of advice if
you want a card break
make your first 15 episodes totally
different to see what's resonating and
what fits good for you
don't pick your format try 10 different
formats in the first 10 episodes
oh yeah that makes complete sense when i
started out i tried out
a bunch of different types of hard
breaks i tried like
somebody gave me an idea for a blind
auction card break i was like sure let
me try it like i haven't seen anybody do
it let me just try it
um but i've also been trying to like
give back
since like i've learned a bunch of stuff
and you know
it's really tough to become a
cardbreaker i've actually started
creating a guide i have a
discord where people could come in they
could host their own card breaks
to try it out to see if they like it
they could ask questions just
all that sort of stuff i even got
pokemon breaking
i love it keep going brother keep going
thanks man appreciate it
take care thank you let's go
hello hey lou hello lou can you get a
rapid fire
maybe four or five of the questions that
you thought possible yeah i'm getting
ready right now and who's up justin
uh diana i figured we should change it
up a little bit
hi hi
gary i've read all your books i'm a huge
fan this is so amazing hi from the
philippines
um i'm a mother and i'm from i'm 39
so i'm old and um so my boyfriend has a
bunch of jordans i'm very happy about
that
but i'm also interested in pokemon
because ever since dustin showed that
big
big ass soft toy and also because yes he
can't tear his um acl and i have two
boys
i have a six and seven year old and i
want to do it as a family thing
and investment long term as well and the
whole contemporary art angle also
has me really intrigued so i want it not
only for fun but
investment for our family this is fun
and a hobby
and a family event that can make you
money
getting into skiing costs money becoming
a disney family
costs money this is crazy that way i
think you're on it and i think pokemon
is as safe as it gets but you have to
get uncomfortably educated
okay 100 hours of watching video and
reading 100. oh
i'm used to uncomfortable good but i
think you're on it and i think it's
gonna be great
and aside from your guide which i will
get into um your guys sharing the link
is there anything else that
um in terms of pokemon so i could really
focus ready for designer
get off right now go on twitter that was
fun gv we're gonna all do that hashtag
it's gonna be my last thing i say here
before we leave
that was fun gb and uh and you could
just say anybody help me with pokemon
there's probably six seven eight people
here that can really help
oh perfect i love it thank you so much
gary you're welcome
see you soon i'll be on tv garyvee soon
i promise i'm going to bug you guys
i can't wait bye
yep um so someone asked about
uh thicker cards so like national
treasures noir
what do you think about those as opposed
to the base stuff again i don't think
size matters i'm
obsessively scared of noir because
they're black and they can't grade well
so i think they're just an incredibly
difficult thing to collect
but if you love collecting raw and
you're not worried about grading then
they're amazing so it just
it comes down to how you see it do you
think 61 flear is too expensive right
now
i think 61 for basketball is grossly
underpriced right now even though it's
gone up 5-10 x
someone was talking about vintage cubies
they said their uncles didn't test the
verdict they were wondering about
investing in vintage cubies
i think vintage qbs are wildly
underpriced
lamar versus mahomes prison base lamar
versus mahomes i think mahomes will have
a better career
but anybody can get hurt at any time um
and then thoughts on soccer we talked
about a little bit basketball talked
about a little bit it's
everybody can come in with your question
that you want to ask right now we'll do
a whole rapid thing and lou will just
keep reading his favorite ones so
astrology
uh listen to card talk i'm gonna i'm
gonna plug card talk real quick yeah go
ahead
uh car talk pod uh 1 37 p.m talk about
cards every week
myself tyler schmidt from team garyvee
um
and ryan johnson card collector two we'd
have like interviews every week we've
done pokemon we've done vintage stuff
we're gonna have gary on soon and me and
him are just gonna argue about vintage
card for like an hour straight it's
gonna be great i see garbage spell kids
in the chat i haven't gone into it yet
the window of garbage bill kids was like
an 18-month phenomenon and i don't think
that was long enough a phenomenon
for it to be like a crazy thing but i
can see it tripling
during this era because we still have
millions of people that are potentially
coming into this hobby
or or investment thing so i think
everything even right now has real
potential
but i don't think that's the most
potential and on the downturn
i think a pikachu red cheeks psa 10 is
better than an
atom bomb psa 10. what do you think
about
grading from uh like the inevitability
of digitized grading and like
i can't i can't wait i can't wait for
the machine to be invented
i i'm trying to get elon musk to invent
it and just
make it and then this way all the
debating and scare goes away but that
would make things vulnerable because if
you have a psa 10
at 40 000 and it comes back a new
machine nine
people can be [ __ ] up but that's
there's risk and everything
i have a little spinning wheel here so i
don't know if dustin if you could see
anywhere
what do you think about the current
lebron james and kevin durant psa nine
rookies
lebron james and kevin rant yeah i think
i think both
i i think kevin durant has the potential
to be the most interesting of them all
because i think people quickly forgot
that he was really the best basketball
player in the world
right the day he got hurt and so i think
um
any place in new york i i think kevin
durant
is extremely interesting high risk some
hot excuse me high upside some risk
depending on how but his game
the way he plays is not reliant on
his injury and so i just think and i
think he's very chip on shoulder
i'm just i'm very bullish on durant lou
you know this i bought
maybe more durant than anything i'm very
bullish on him and i think psa nine is
an incredibly interesting category
as things get expensive i even think psa
eight
for the not ultra modern but the modern
call it the 2006
2010 back is even an interesting debate
someone asked about i can't find it now
sgc over psa
you know it's interesting andrew you
probably know i'm very fond of sgc i
think they're extremely difficult
on grading i know there's that one viral
post where a 10 sgc got a
six psa but like you see that all the
time in every direction like
i think sgc is tough greeting i like the
black case personally i know that's
completely a subjective opinion
everybody likes different cases i think
there's three companies i think there's
psa bgs and
sgc and i i submit a lot
probably more than the norm to sgc and
and i get mad about it because i get
back bad grades
but i just like their cases uh sports
car
sports cards depends on the players
skills but what do you what about
pokemon
what are their what makes them i guess
favorite than someone else
the community of pokemon people getting
excited about characters or
new original programming kind of like
star wars
if pokemon starts doing content on
netflix
around squirtle just on a six-part
series on that that's going to build up
demand and so
um future behavior with the ip is going
to change the outcome
just like in the comic book world nobody
gave a [ __ ] about black panther
and then all of a sudden they know
movies coming and everybody does
same thing with pokemon over the next 30
years things will pop
up whether it's toys whether it's cards
whether it's a video game whether it's a
movie whether it's a
mini series on spotify that will feature
a specific
pokemon and that might change the market
dramatically
all right i gotta go i hope everybody
enjoyed uh hope this brought you some
value
hope everybody's super well thank you
for being a part of this
uh to continue this incredible community
please go to twitter right now hashtag
that was fun gv that was fun gv
use that hashtag um let me just put it
in here so everybody there's no
mistaking it
let's check that was fun tv
there you go um and i hope everybody's
well good luck
see ya hey everybody on youtube first of
all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want a watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out